people ask me all the time and a lot of
people a lot of fans have favorite songs
that are actually from the oh so let's
not say the name of the album slash
soundtrack yeah there was a time when
Mariah Carey wouldn't even say the word
glitter wasn't even an album and it gave
me hell for it but now Mariah is fully
embracing her 2001 movie and soundtrack
changing her username on Twitter to
Billy Frank her character from the film
no matter what happens with this movie I
really it's really helped me grow the
whole process of acting the whole
process of doing this particular movie
has helped me grow as a person and
nearly two years after her fans started
the justice for glitter movement which
sent the soundtrack to number one on
iTunes glitter is now available on music
streaming services for the first time
ever this has been one of the best
experiences I've had making a record
doing the soundtrack and I got a chance
because you know to work with some of
the people that I grew up really
admiring I mean I don't know what's
ultimately going to end up on the
soundtrack but I had I had a little
collaborative moment with Prince with
Rick James Jimmy Jam and Terry Lewis
everybody that really made the early 80s
he was on set with Mariah in 2004 the
movie what happens in this scene is
Billy my character is discovered by the
record executives she's already made my
character and dice my boyfriend and the
movie have already made their first
record but it's not it's like a private
you know white label thing and so they
played in the clubs and she performs
them in clubs and on this particular
night she gets discovered by CMZ which
in our fictitious world is a very big
label this is my latest track
and this is the singing of Billy Frank
people are gonna say this sounds a
little familiar right well it would
sound familiar if she went with the
record guy but she absolutely does not
so therefore it is nothing like that at
all the boyfriend is a young cute DJ and
they end up together why would have been
good I played it up you can let Tim to
use the best of you it would makes you
think that's investment so the dynamic
of her being a singer is the same and so
therefore some of the circumstance is
like getting discovered and things like
that to happen but that's not really
what it's about
there's a lot more in the movie than
just the whole becoming a star thing
Terrence Howard Max Beesley and a brat
rounded out the cast but Padma Lakshmi
as silk a singer who can't sing is a
standout
[Music]
pariah was on a mission with glitter
which was her first project after
leaving ex-husband Tommy Mottola x'
label Sony records my first project of
2000 is going to be my first leading
role in a movie which is called all the
glitters but the project was plagued
with leaks when is this gonna run I want
people to do this before the movie comes
out that I'm gonna look like I copied
them a sample Mariah cleared for the
lead single lover boy ended up on
another artists album almost a year
before glitters release if you sit back
and focus on it it does drive you crazy
and I'm not saying that I don't like go
out and at ange and get mad about stuff
when things happen sometimes but the
truth of the matter is I'm blessed to be
here and to be able to do all the things
that I'm doing as the release date for
the album neared it became clear that
Mariah's non-stop schedule including a
second movie wise girls was becoming too
much I am in control but then also they
think I'm five years old and so
sometimes they like to tell me what to
do with every aspect of my life but oh
there goes the music see I'm not control
of that but anyway that's atmospheric
noise some from the video shoot we're
working with it we go with it as we flow
anyway so I'm in control but I'm out of
control and I'm also um controlled so in
a way I'm everything the glitter
soundtrack was unfortunately released on
September 11th 2001 my fans already know
that I'm a workaholic and then I'm an
insomniac and what I do is I work myself
into the ground but that's like my
problems are miniscule compared to
what's going on with our country tonight
I'm just thankful to be here to be alive
I think you know the movie is about you
know it's a nice story it's it's a
little bit you know people get a little
emotional but it's a good story there's
some light moments and luckily Mariah
went on to find continued success in
movies and music and later this year
we'll release her memoir I've kind of
had to go through the struggles that
I've gone through not even what people
think were my struggles because honestly
that whole like moment of the
quote-unquote breakdown was so overly
dramatized a lot of the most difficult
times in my life happened before I was
famous and then during the period of
time that people think was my like oh
wow she must have been
happy this must have been like yay
amazing time period in my life
career-wise personally was really not a
good time not a good place to be
[Music]